at that time michael keaton was the lead
actor
well the deal went awry i don't know the
details but the deal
went awry so production was sidelined
what was the original version of pretty
woman the original version was
titled 3000 spelled out which was the
number of dollars that edward pays
vivian for her
companionship for the week
it was a drama it was not a picture
where boy and girl end up together
and in in in some ways it was a much
more realistic story
and i think it was very reflective of
the writers sort of
the world that he lived in and the way
he was feeling about things at the time
but there was something undeniably
here's what i would say about it
jonathan
when he was in film school he kept
writing these very complex
really interesting leading women
characters
and i remember one of our early
conversations before we started working
together he let
on that one of his professors presumably
a male as i recall
wagged his finger at him and basically
said you know leave that alone let the
women write women characters you focus
on
blah blah which was like waving a red
flag in front of a bull
uh john one of the things i'd say that
we shared in common was
a certain reverence for women
and that showed up in all of his scripts
no matter how fl and they were all
flawed
but they were absolutely magnificent and
one of the things i would say about his
character his women elite
lead lead women characters was that they
were inevitably the moral superior in
every given
any given story and i would say that was
one of the
things that really stood out for me in
this sort of
grittier world of hollywood
uh or the collision of these two worlds
the investment banker from new york and
the girl from the streets of hollywood
coming together this unlikely duo
where he had a certain wound a certain
skepticism a certain you know
agenda based on his relationship with
his dad and his life experience
his current girlfriend and then she
despite her circumstances was
this ineffable spirit who had this sort
of moral code
she was just a delightful character
um who's making the best of her
circumstances
and er there was something so alluring
to me about
her in this original script 3000.
so while it didn't end well i just saw
that the relationship
and who she was was such a
unexpected construction
and i i i i i
i figure i'm like a really good audience
i'm like
i am almost like the perfect audience to
read a script
i i don't read it when i get a script i
never read it as if i'm the producer
i try not to read it as up on the
director or the financier or the
distributor or any of those hats
the closest thing i would say is i try
to read it as if i'm going to be the
lead actor but more importantly i try to
read it as if i am the audience
because that's ultimately who i am right
and that script was was
i a must-see story for me
so my belief in it was a thousand
percent it was like
it wouldn't matter how many no's i heard
that was going to be i was going to do
anything possible to get that film made
and originally it was
intended to be made as as scripted
as a lower budgeted you know several
million dollar independent film
because it was set in just a room in a
hotel
right we we didn't have a lot of
production value
to worry about um but
the i guess the the authenticity of both
the lead characters
was so undeniable
uh it was written like he knew these
people deeply and then the supporting
cast
jonathan had a gift as well
there's no such thing as a secondary
character they may be supporting
they may not have a lot of dialogue or
page count but
no one in that story is not important
said the hotel manager even the elevator
opera you know
even before it became a comedy you could
see these
we were witnessing with and through the
eyes of these people and they were so
interesting on their in their own right
so it was
i don't know if that answers your
question but it was absolutely
a mesmerizing read how obsessed were you
with the screenplay when you first read
it i wish i could take it back to the
moment i closed the script cover because
i was i it was a script that i
um i know that if i can't stop reading
which i didn't i read it copper to cover
in one sitting
which is not that extraordinary but uh
but it's a good sign
uh but what i know when i closed the
screen cover i was speechless
like i had just experienced something
probably the most special script at that
young juncture of my career
that i'd read to date um
and i could see it it's it's
there's something about a brilliant
screenplay that draws you and it takes
you on a journey that is so
detailed and and emotive
uh where the characters are so different
or unexpected
um that you feel yourself literally
being pulled
into the story and
that was the case with three thousand it
was certainly
i was i was devastated at the end
but apart from the being devastated
because of the reality of the story
and the experience of the characters
when i closed that script however
i was a bit stunned into silence like i
know i have a movie
i for the first time you know i this is
like i want this to be a movie i produce
it's the first time i said that to
myself
um and
i i don't really you know honestly it's
almost like you go blank
after that and i don't remember all the
particular conversations that we had but
i know i
immediately reached out to jonathan and
said i am so happy we're working
together
this is this is a special script scripts
are fascinating
creatures and sometimes there's
something that really stands out it
might be a particular character it might
be the world it might be the
descriptions it could be
dialogue it could there was something
about 3000 where the whole of it
was just right and all of it drew me in
what was interesting was when i finished
reading it i was so excited and yet i
was also very
pragmatic i realized i was still
relatively new in the business
i mean certainly i hadn't produced
except for a couple of micro budget
little you know but i hadn't produced
anything the world knew
and jonathan was still relatively
unknown
he was not yet an established name
but what i held in my hand merited
a lot of attention and the question was
how do i get from here to there
how do i create that energy
and the one thing that occurred to me
was
i think this is such an artful
compelling
beautifully crafted story that
it lives at the level of the early like
extremely rarefied atmosphere that was
sundance institute so i called up
um i had befriended michelle satter who
was
you know sat at the right hand of robert
redford since day one building the
institute building the festival and
all of all that it had become and they
had all these beautiful
labs and workshops and they had one
called the production
lab where they would pick i don't know
a limited number eight ten perhaps
projects and invite them once a year
it was maybe a week-long event and you
would go to utah
and you would workshop the project
meaning you would have
a level talent show up uh all these
resource people would show for free
editors cinematographers actors you name
it
and so you would take that script and
break it down and you'd start
videotaping scenes with these actors and
sort of trying to you know
find what's working how to improve it
etc
so i sent it to michelle and she um
quite quickly called me back and said
i want this project i want you i want to
invite you guys to
come as the writer producer so we did
and it was one of those exalted
moments that you'll never forget because
when you're
still relatively you know you're you're
at the lower end of the ladder you're
climbing the ladder
and then you're invited to sundance
already amazing
but beyond that one day i remember i
could
i see the scene i'm sitting there and
there are actors and there are the video
cameras
and jonathan's there and a bunch of
other people
and we have these wonderful actors
playing edward and vivian
and we shot a scene and suddenly uh i
hear a voice whispering notes in my ear
what if and
i look just like i thought i was
dreaming this
man that was whispering in my ear was
paul hirsch
editor of star wars editor of you know
an oscar
winning you know like 50 of the greatest
films ever
and he is offering me creative notes
it was like i died and gone to heaven
it was a magical experience to see this
sort of come to life
in that venue and
of course hollywood took notice that was
the whole idea well one of the inciting
ideas was i want people to i want this
in the trades i want people to see
that by association
this is a quality project uh
and that and it worked the phone started
ringing people were
very interested it started to have this
sort of create this
this cause celeb this buzz this energy
um
the script had a consistent it's been
taught in film schools
it had that sort of consistent response
it was one of those rare scripts that
sort of hits everybody where they live
everyone can relate to the humanity of
this story
and so we were very blessed that way and
that you know obviously like every film
it travels a very twisted journey and
it goes off the cliff here and it dies
by a thousand paper cuts over there and
and so on but you stay with it and um
i don't know if i've ever shared the i
sent it
wide option to best run and then i got
it back out and then i optioned it to
new regency and we were still stalled we
couldn't get it financed or cast
richard had richard gary turned the
project down
and during that time back when i was at
restaurant i had
friends mark and scott who produced
mystic pizza which is
just such a brilliant film and when the
lights came up of this little friends
and family screening to get feedback
before they locked picture
i had i had no criticism to offer
but i saw this girl on the screen and i
said i i don't know who she is but will
you introduce me and that was
julia roberts and they did they were
very kind
and um julia and her then manager read
it
and was attached for three years before
we actually went into production
but unexpectedly because hollywood is
nothing
if not non-linear right it's full of
surprise
so i sent it to someone i had known when
he was a junior
a lesser executive somewhere and then he
became a senior vp at touchstone
and i sent it as a writing sample saying
this is not disney material it's about a
prostitute
but you're going to absolutely flip
you're going to fall in love with the
craft this writer is someone you need to
know
and we're going to come in a week heads
you'll read it we'll come in next week
and we will pitch you
a couple of more disney appropriate
stories
it was only several days before the
phone rang and and and
the call was we want to buy it
and i was taken a little back and i said
gosh
are we talking about the same script
well we were
and um i mean there's a there's a lesson
in this for
everyone in this business like you
cannot know what's happening behind the
curtain you don't
know all the forces or influences that
are at play
disney touchstone in this case had a
the wonderful project what about bob
and it was going in depression with gary
marshall directing and dianne critten
and casting in the full laura siskind
line producing and
they had the full team and at that time
michael keaton was
the lead actor well the deal
went awry i don't know the details but
the deal went awry
so production was sidelined
and they thought gosh we have gary we
have
this team assembled and they looked at
our script and thought
great we'll create a marriage.
so there was this meeting a week later
that was no longer a pitch meeting
it was about we want to buy this script
and we just want to know can you lighten
it
the question actually from the president
of the studio was on the disney
lightning scale this is a foreign we'd
like it to be a seven can you do that
and i answered absolutely yes we can do
that
um because it was pretty evident what
they were asking
and
as a result we not only inherited
i i mean i i'm not so brilliant that i
would have thought
of gary marshall directing this
particular film
and we were fortunate because i'd never
had a big studio a
major director and a deep pocket so i
went back to richard gere's agent ed
lamotto and said
please because ed loved the project
would you go back to richard now
and the studio backed it and they made
him the sort of the godfather offer
that you couldn't refuse and so richard
finally said yes
and the beauty of that was they've been
auditioning and meeting and screen
testing
um many many many actors
both for the male and female lead and
you know it's it's there's sort of a lot
of it's it's public information there's
you know the long list of name actors
and actresses who
who who sort of paraded through um
and fortunately many of them declined um
either passed on it or whatever for
whatever reason it didn't happen
but julia was not on their radar she was
like an unknown actress
at the time she had shot steel magnolias
but it hadn't come out
and she was so you know mystic pizza
wonderful movie but she was not yet sort
of
well known to either the public or or
the studios
but now with richard if you have your
anchor
tenant right then it was like okay now
this is possible just maybe i just
wanted them to screen test together that
would have been all
my dream right and
so i you know
i lobbied and said you know this is but
it had to be gary marshall
and the idea was gary meet her alone
just the two of you
and you're going to fall in love
and that happened so when gary marshall
versus gary goldstein says to the
c-suite of hollywood of a major studio
this is my girl i want to screen test it
happened and once they did
it was it was so undeniable
so the journey of a film is so uh
unknowable
so unpredictable and that we ended up
with our dreamcast and it turns out a
dream director i didn't know
was even in my dream uh is
it's you know it's the stuff that you
can't you can't make up
just happens
you